The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK,
today's lecture will
begin with photon
states, which is
a very interesting
application of what
we've learned about
coherent states.
And in a sense, it's
an advanced topic.
Photon states are states of
the electromagnetic field.
They are quantum states of
You A photon, this
particle, is a quantum
of the electromagnetic field.
There's a discrete piece of
energy and momentum carried
by this particle.
So when we talk
about photon states,
we're really doing
quantum field theory.
So in some sense,
this lecture, you
will see how quantum
field theory works.
A first introduction to
quantum field theory.
And it's interesting that
the harmonic oscillator
plays such an
important role in that.
So a key identity that we
are going to use, of course,
is this coherent
states that were
defined as displacements
of the vacuum.
For D, if I remember
right, was e
to the alpha a dagger
minus alpha star a.
And it had the property
that a acting on alpha
was equal to alpha--
alpha, the operator a.
So these were the
coherent states
we've been talking about.
And today we're going to
talk about photon states.
So that will be probably
about half of the lecture.
And in the second
half of the lecture,
we will begin a more systematic
study of two-state systems.
Two-state systems, of
course, are our spin states,
are the classical
two-state system.
And we're going to sort
of put it all together.
We'll understand the general
dynamics of a two-spin system,
what is the most general
Hamiltonian you can have,
and therefore the
most General Dynamics.
And then we'll solve that.
And we'll have two
physical examples,
one having to deal with
the ammonia molecule.
And another having to do with
nuclear magnetic resonance.
Both are applications
of two-state systems.
So till it's the end of the
lecture, we'll be doing that.
So about photon states.
Well, photon states have to do
with electromagnetic fields.
That's electric and
magnetic fields.
And one important
quantity that you
know about the electromagnetic
fields is the energy.
If you have an electromagnetic
field, you have an energy.
And remember, energies have
to do with Hamiltonians.
So we're going to
try to do a quantum
description of the
electromagnetic field.
Therefore, knowing the energy
would be a good place to start.
So the energy, as you know,
in an electromagnetic field
goes like e squared times
some epsilon and b squared.
And you add the two of them.
So here we go.
Let me write a precise formula.
The energy is equal
to 1/2 the integral
over volume, epsilon 0,
the electric field squared,
plus c squared times the
magnetic field squared.
So this is our energy.
And we're going
to try to describe
a configuration of
electromagnetic fields.
We will to focus on one mode
of the electromagnetic field.
So I will imagine I have some
sort of cavity, finite volume.
And in there I have one
electromagnetic field,
what you usually called in
802 or in 8022 or 807 a wave.
A single wave with some
wavelength, some frequency,
and that's all we have.
So we're going to
simplify to the case
where we have a single one
consistent with Maxwell's
equations and some boundary
conditions that we need not
worry about.
And I will normalize them
as follows with a V in here.
That this is the
volume of the system.
So, volume.
And that could be the
volume of the cavity that
has this electromagnetic field.
Or some large box.
Or you can let it almost be
infinite and work with that
as well.
So we'll have a wave.
Omega would be the frequency.
K is omega over c for
a electromagnetic wave.
So we'll have this
times omega sine
of kz, a spatial distribution.
And there will be a function
of time, as you know.
But this function
of time, I want
to leave it a little ambiguous
at this moment-- or, general.
Not ambiguous, general.
So I'll call it q of t,
some function of time
to be determined.
There's going to be an
electromagnetic and magnetic
component to this field, By.
c times By will also
depend on z and t
and will have the
same pre-factor.
I put the c here.
So your c squared b
squared also works well.
Epsilon 0 v.
This time I'll put another
function, p of t cosine of kz.
It's another function of time
and I just call them that way.
There is a question there.
STUDENT: Why is your frequency
outside your function of time?
PROFESSOR: It's just
another constant here.
STUDENT: What would
that mean then?
PROFESSOR: No particular
meaning to it.
At this moment,
whatever this constant
is you would say
probably it's useful
because you somehow
wanted the q here.
That has some meaning.
So you probably would put
the same constants here
in first trial.
You wouldn't have
this omega here.
But if you put it, this
is just another way
of changing their own
manifestation of q.
So it doesn't have a
profound meaning so far.
Any other questions about this?
This is and electromagnetic
field configuration.
And this q of t and p of
t are functions of time.
You know your
Maxwell's equations.
And you will check things
related to Maxwell's equations
for this configuration
in the homework.
But at this moment,
it's not too crucial.
The thing that this
important is that we
can try to calculate
the energy now.
And if you do it, well, the
squares, the epsilon 0's
are going to disappear.
And you're going to
have to integrate
over the box, this integral of
sine squared of kz or cosine
squared of kz.
The functions of
time don't matter--
this energy could
depend on time.
And the way we've prepared
is when you integrate over
sine squared of kz,
if the box is big,
it's a good situation where you
can replace that for 1/2, which
is the average, and 1/2
for the average of this.
Or you could define
where the box extends,
from what values of z to
what other values of z's.
And so the integral, in fact,
is not any complicated integral.
And we have
immediately the answer
that energy is 1/2 p squared
of t plus omega squared q
squared of t.
And that was why
this omega was here.
There's not really much to this.
Except that when you square
it and you take the integral
over the volume, you replace
the sine squared by 1/2
and the cosine squared by 1/2.
And that's it.
So actually, the labels
that we've chosen here
are pretty good.
This starts to look like
a harmonic oscillator.
Except that the mass is gone.
1 over 2m p squared should
be plus 1/2 m omega squared
q squared.
So the units are wrong here.
p squared over 2m
has units of energy.
But p squared doesn't
have units of energy.
And 1/2 m omega squared q
squared has units of energy
but this one doesn't.
So the units are a little off
for a harmonic oscillator.
So it's interesting
to notice now.
But you couldn't
have done better.
Because photons have no mass.
And we're trying to describe
the electromagnetic field.
It has photons.
So there's no way this could
have showed up a mass there.
There's no such thing.
And that's why it
doesn't show up.
On the other hand,
you can say, well, OK,
let's see if this makes
a minimum of sense.
How do we deal with this unit?
So p has units of
square root of energy.
And q has units of time
times square root of energy.
Why is that?
Because omega has
units of 1 over time.
So q over time
squared is energy.
So q is t times
square root of energy.
And therefore p doesn't have the
right units to deserve the name
p.
And q doesn't have the right
units to deserve the name q.
But p times q has the
units of time times energy,
which are the units of h bar.
So that's good.
This p and q have the
right units in some sense.
So this thing could be viewed
as an inspiration for you.
And you say at
this moment, well,
I don't know what is a quantum
of an electromagnetic field.
But here I have a
natural correspondence
between one mode of
vibration, classical,
of the electromagnetic field,
and an energy functional
that looks exactly like
a harmonic oscillator.
So I will declare these things
to be a Hamiltonian and this p
of t and q of t to be
the Heisenberg operators
of the electromagnetic field.
So what we're saying
now is that I'm
going to just call
the Hamiltonian 1/2 p
hat squared plus omega
squared q hat squared.
This is a time
independent Hamiltonian.
If you're doing Heisenberg,
it's the same thing
as the Hamiltonian that
would have p hat square of t
plus omega q hat squared of t.
Now, at this moment,
this might sound to you
just too speculative.
But you can do a couple of
checks that this is reasonable.
So one check, remember that the
Hamiltonian-- quantum equations
of motion, of
Heisenberg operators
should look like classical
equations of motion.
So I can now compute
what are the Heisenberg
equation of motions
for the operators.
Remember something like v
dt of p Heisenberg of t dt
is related to h
with p Heisenberg.
And you can calculate the
Heisenberg equations of motion.
I may have signs wrong here.
Nevertheless, you know those
for the harmonic oscillator
and you can write them.
But you also know
Maxwell's equations.
And you can plug into
And that's one check you will do
in homework, in which you will
take Maxwell's
equations and see what
equations you have
for q of t p of t.
And then they will
be exactly the same
as the Heisenberg equations
of motion of this Hamiltonian,
giving you evidence that this
is a reasonable thing to do.
That we can think of this
dynamical system with q and p
being quantum operators.
So let's accept that this is
a Hamiltonian for this quantum
system that we
want to work with.
And therefore, write the
operators that we have.
And what are they?
Well, we had
formulas with masses.
But now mass goes to 1.
So know the units.
You cannot let in general in a
formula mass going to 1 unless
you're going to do
something with the units.
But we agreed already that these
p's and q's have funny units.
So those units are in fact
consistent with a mass
that has no units.
And you can set it equal to 1.
So I claim that you can take
all the formulas we had with m
and just put m equals to 1
and nothing would go wrong.
Nothing goes funny.
So in particular,
you had an expression
for x that now is called q terms
of creation and annihilation
operators and now
that reads-- And you
have an expression for p.
And that one reads
now a minus a dagger.
These formulas used
to have m's in there.
And I've just set m equals to 1.
And that should be
the right thing.
Unit-wise, indeed h bar
omega has units of energy.
And we claim that p has units of
energy, square root of energy.
So this is fine.
So what else do we get
from this Hamiltonian?
Well, we can write it in
terms of the number operators.
So this Hamiltonian now,
it's equal to h bar omega
a dagger a plus 1/2.
And this is just because this
p and q written in this way
corresponds to m equals to 1.
And m doesn't show up
anyway in this formula.
So no reason to be worried
that anything has gone wrong.
And this is H equals to h
bar omega, N hat plus 1/2.
And this is a number operator.
And then you get
the interpretation,
the physical interpretation
that if you have states
with some number operator, the
energy is the number times h
omega, which is exactly
what we think about photons.
If you have N photons
in a given state,
you would have an energy
N times h bar omega.
So it may look a little
innocent what we've done here.
But this is a
dramatic assumption.
You've really done something
that took physicists 30 years
to figure out, how to
do quantum field theory.
And of course, this is
just the very beginning.
And there's lots of
things to learn about it.
But the first thing
that is happening
is that somehow--
look what's happening.
In normal quantum mechanics, x
and p became quantum operators.
In a sense here, this q
and p are like x and p.
But they have nothing to do with
usual position and momentum.
Nothing absolutely.
q is like E really.
And p is like B.
So who has become
a quantum operator?
Not x and p, in a sense.
E and B have become
quantum operators.
Quantum field theory is
the idea that the fields
become operators.
That's what's really happening.
And it seems to be
right in the sense
that our intuition that
the state with N photos
would be viewed as a
state of a harmonic
oscillator, an usual
one with mass equals 1.
So that this really
is not a momentum
and this is not a position.
But they behave as that.
So we can turn now this
formula to its Heisenberg form
so that q of t is square
root of h bar over 2 omega.
Remember a as a function of
time becomes e to the minus
i omega t a hat--
that's the Heisenberg
version of a-- plus e to the
plus i omega t a hat dagger.
So given that, we
can substitute back
to our electric field
that has this omega here,
that has this factor in there.
So I will write it
all together here.
Therefore, Ex of z t-- and
now I've put a hat here.
And z t, the t is the t of
a Heisenberg operator now.
Is equal to E naught e to
the minus i omega t a plus
e to the i omega t a
hat dagger sine of kz,
where this constant E zero is
h bar omega over epsilon 0 V.
It's just a mnemonic for
some constant at this moment.
So we plugged-in here,
there's all these factors.
There's the omega
and there's the q.
So all these factors
together give you this.
The factor and sine of kz.
And this is the
electromagnetic field operator.
The electric field is not
anymore an electric field.
It's an operator.
So if we want to
get an intuition
about this electric
field operator,
let's try to find its
expectation value.
It's an operator.
The closest thing we can have
an intuition about an operator
is its expectation value.
So very good.
Let's take a photon
state and energy
eigenstate of the harmonic
oscillator of occupation number
n.
And we have a state now of n
photons, an energy eigenstate.
In fact, with energy n h omega
plus this 1/2 h bar omega.
And let's figure out
what is the expectation
value of Ex in that state n.
So we go to this formula.
And we say, OK, it's E naught
e to the minus i omega t n--
and we're all very curious.
We want to see how the
electromagnetic field
of the n-th state of the
harmonic oscillator, n
photons in an energy eigenstate,
how does that wave look?
Let's see.
n a hat n plus e to the i
omega t n a dagger n sine kz.
So this is a field operator.
So we put it in a
state and we want
to know how does the
field look in that state.
And how much do we get?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 0.
OK, that seems a little strange.
Because indeed,
the matrix element
of a in an energy
eigenstate is 0.
This reduces, makes n minus
1 [INAUDIBLE] to this.
So this is 0.
And this is n plus 1 n.
This is 0.
So actually no great
illumination nation
has happened.
We got 0.
So actually this
is not too strange.
Energy eigenstates
are very unintuitive.
The energy eigenstate of
a harmonic oscillator,
the n-th state is some sort
of wave that is like that.
Nothing changes in
time in that wave.
Nothing all that
interesting happens.
So the fact that this
electromagnetic field operator
has zero expectation value
on this n photon state
is maybe not too surprising.
So let's take a more
thoughtful state.
We've said so many times
that coherent states
act like classical states.
So let's put a coherent state
of photons into this state.
So let's see.
Now the state will
be an alpha state,
which is a coherent state.
And therefore, the expectation
value of Ex on the alpha state
will be equal to E
not e to the minus i
omega t alpha a alpha
plus e to the plus
i omega t alpha a hat
dagger alpha sine of kz.
Well, we're in better shape now.
a on alpha is the
number alpha, as we
reviewed at the beginning.
And then alpha with alpha is 1.
Remember, it's a unitary
transform of the vacuum.
Therefore, this
whole thing is alpha.
So this is E not alpha being a
number e to the minus i omega
t plus here is alpha star e
to the i omega t sine of kz.
And now we're very happy.
The coherent state is the state
for which the expectation value
of the electromagnetic
field is precisely
the kind of waves you've
seen all your life.
This wave, travelling
waves, stationary waves.
All those only appeared
because only on coherent states
a and a dagger have
expectation values.
So what we really call a
classical wave resonating
in a cavity is a coherent state
of the electromagnetic field
in this sense.
The state of photons
form a coherent state.
They're not an energy ion state.
They're not positioned
for anything.
They're not the number
eigen states either,
because they're not
energy eigen states.
They have uncertainties.
But they have a nice,
classical picture.
The expectation value of
the operator is a real wave.
So any time in 802 or in 8022,
you have a classical wave
to analyze, the quantum
description of that wave
is a coherent state of
the electromagnetic field.
Lasers are coherent states
of the electromagnetic field.
They have these uncertainties
that we discussed
last time with number and
phase that are very strong.
If the number goes large,
then certainty on the face
is extremely small.
So there we go.
This is a coherent state.
We can do a little more on
that, write it more explicitly.
This is epsilon 2 E
not, the real part
of alpha e to the minus
i omega t sine of kz.
And if we write,
for example, alpha
to be length of alpha
e to the i theta,
then this would be 2 E not.
Length of alpha would
go out, and the i theta
to minus i omega
t would give you
cosine of omega t
minus theta sine of kz.
And this is something
like a standing wave.
It just changes in time and with
a fixed spatial distribution.
So it's a classical wave,
and nevertheless, it
has a good description
classically,
a good description
quantum mechanically.
It's a coherent state.
And its energy is
the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian.
The expectation
value of the energy--
let me write this expectation
value-- of H is H omega.
Expectation value of N plus 1/2.
And in a coherent state,
the expectation value of N
is alpha squared.
So you have this of
the coherent state
alpha has alpha squared photons.
And that's because it's
the number operator,
and that's pretty much the end
of our story for photon states.
There's more that one could do.
One could do basically all
kinds of things put together
different modes.
We considered here one mode.
You could consider
electric fields
have super procession
of modes and discuss
commutation relations
for the field operators,
and all kinds of things.
But that's really a quantum
field theory course.
At this moment, the main
story I wanted to get across
is that naturally, the harmonic
oscillator has entered here,
but in a very funny way.
q and p were not
positioned in momentum,
were basically electric
field and magnetic field.
And there's an
uncertainty between
electric and magnetic fields.
And the result of all this is
that at the end of the day,
you have a description
by a harmonic oscillator
and with energy
levels that correspond
to different amount of
photons in the field.
Finally, the classical
things, if you
want to recover
classical waves, you
must consider coherence states.
These are the states
that were classical.
When you looked at the harmonic
oscillator doing motion
and for electromagnetic
field, they
give you the
classical wave picture
of an electric and
magnetic field oscillating
in position and time.
So are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If we're associating
h bar with [INAUDIBLE], what
object would you associate
the zero point energy with?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
a zero point energy
of this quantum of vibration.
So just like an
electromagnetic field,
basically, if this
is like q and p,
there's a minimum
energy state in which
you're in the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator.
But E and B cannot be zero, like
delta x and delta p cannot be
zero.
So every mode of the
electromagnetic field
has a zero point energy.
You cannot reduce it.
So the vacuum of the
electromagnetic field
has a lot of zero
point energies,
one for every mode of radiation.
Now, that zero point energies
don't get you in trouble
unless you're trying
to do gravity.
Gravity's the universal force
and universal interaction
that notes every bit of energy.
So your zero point
energies are quite
important if you
consider gravity.
And you would have encountered
here the first complication
associated with
quantum field theory.
Every mode of the
electromagnetic field--
a frequency one, a
frequency 1.1, a frequency
1.2-- every one of them
has a ground state energy
of 1/2H bar omega.
If you add them all
up, you get infinity.
So you get an infinity
of ground state energies.
And people have learned how
to work with this infinities.
That infinity is not physical.
But, if you suitably
treat it, you
can figure out all
kinds of things.
And there's several
people, I think
even some
undergraduates, working
on this with Professor
Kardar and Professor Jaffe,
called Casimir energies,
in which the zero point
energies of the
electromagnetic field
are treated in a
more careful way,
and the infinities are
seen to be irrelevant,
but there are some
physical dependence
on the parameters
that keeps there.
So you see the origin of
this is because every mode
of the electromagnetic field
has a zero point energy, just
like any quantum oscillator.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
PROFESSOR: Well,
uncountable things,
we already have seen some.
Maybe they didn't look
that sophisticated,
but we had position states
that were uncountable.
So the electromagnetic field,
yes, it has uncountable things.
And there's nothing
wrong about it.
You just have to
work with integrals.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, no, no.
They're not really normalized
because just like these states,
the position states
are not normalized,
they're delta function
normalized and things
like that.
So look, if you want to avoid
conceptual troubles with that,
people and many
physicists and textbooks
on quantum field theory begin
with space, a big, big, box.
And then you see that it
works for any size box,
and then you say, well, it will
work if the box is infinite.
And we just proceed.
All right.
So I'll move on now to the
second part of the lecture
that deals with two-state
systems and spin
states and goes back and puts
together a few of the things
we've been doing.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you
close the sun shade?
I can't really see the board.
PROFESSOR: OK, sure.
Board.
I think maybe we
need all the way?
No, that won't
make a difference.
It's the other shades, I think.
I'll leave it like that.
Maybe I should use another
board for the people
that watch these movies.
That may be better.
So let's do this board.
OK, so here's what we
want to understand.
Two-state systems.
It's probably going
to be about this,
and two more lectures on that.
And what we want to understand
first is spin procession.
You say, well, spin
procession looks
like a very particular
kind of problem.
When you have spins, you
have magnetic fields.
But at the end of the
day, what we will see
is that spin process-- you
can view any two-state system
as a system in which you've
put a spin in a magnetic field.
Even though you may be
talking about electrons
shared between two atoms, or
ammonia molecule, or anything
like that.
Mathematically, you go
back always to spins.
Because spins are things we
have become familiar already.
So we exploit that
to the maximum.
So we do the one thing we
haven't done rigorously so far,
and then we'll explore
this analogy to some point.
So what was our
discussion of spin?
So two-state systems, and we'll
begin with spin procession.
So the idea of spin procession
all arises, as you remember,
because if you have a charged
particle that has some spin,
there's a relation between
the particle's magnetic moment
and the spin, or the angular
momentum, of that particle,
of that little ball of material.
And we made an argument
that this was just
q over 2m times the
angular momentum.
And this will be
This was classical.
Nevertheless, the
fact that we claim
is true quantum mechanically
is that in fact this idea is
roughly right, except that
there's two modifications.
The true magnetic moment that
enters into the Hamiltonian
under the particle has
is not quite the same
as suggested by the
classical argument,
but it's modified by a g factor.
And that modification
is important.
And this S is not just a plain
classical angular momentum
of a rotated ball with
some mass and some radius,
but it's a spin angular momentum
and intrinsic angular momentum.
A rather abstract
thing that in fact
should be best viewed
as an operator,
and that's the way
we've thought about it.
The magnetic [INAUDIBLE]
now becomes an operator,
because it's proportional
to the spin operator.
So it's an operator.
And different values of g
apply for different particles.
And we saw that g equals 2
applies for the electron.
That's a famous value,
in fact predicted
by Dirac's equation,
relativistic equation,
for the electron, and observed
to great accuracy of course
as well.
And for other particles, like
the proton or the neutron,
the quantity g has
different values.
You might be surprised that the
neutron has a dipole moment.
Because you would say a neutron
is an uncharged particle,
so a charge rotating
doesn't do anything.
Nevertheless, a
neutron is uncharged,
but it has three quarks,
two with some charge, one
with an opposite charge
to the other two.
And if they distribute cleverly,
say the negative ones are
farther away from the
center, and in the center
is the positive one, this could
have angular magnetic moment.
And in fact, it does
have magnetic moment.
The neutron has a
significant magnetic moment.
So at the end of
the day, we're going
to write this as
mu equal gamma S.
And this constant gamma is going
to summarize everything, g, q,
m, all these things.
And this will be
a good notation.
Gamma S is brief and simple.
And this constant,
we're going to use it.
So the Hamiltonian minus mu
dot B is a quantum Hamiltonian
because mu is an operator.
B, at this moment, even
though we were just
talking about
photon states, this
will be a static
magnetic field typically.
Can be a to time
dependent, but it will not
be sufficiently important
if it has time dependence,
and we have to quantize it and
to think of it as a quantum
field.
But in some problems
of radiation
of electromagnetic fields
by the motion of spins,
you would have to quantize
the electromagnetic field.
But this is not the case now.
So this is minus gamma S
dot B. And we typically
like to write it as
minus gamma B dot S.
And that means very explicitly
minus gamma BxSx operator
plus BySy operator
plus BzSz operator.
So let me remind you of
a simple situation when
you had a magnetic field
in the z direction.
B along z if B is B times z hat.
Then H is minus gamma.
BSz.
And the unitary operator
that generates time evolution
of states, the unitary operator
u of t0 is exponential minus i.
I'll call it H sub s for spin.
H sub s t over H bar.
And I'll put it like this
exponential of minus i minus
gamma B t Sz over H bar.
So I substituted
what Hs is, moved
the t sort of inside the
parentheses minus gamma B Sz.
I put the z out
and put this here.
So far so good?
This is our time
development operator.
Now, I want you to recall
one property that you only
justified by checking
it in the homework.
But in the next few
lectures, we will just
make sure you understand this
why it's true in general.
But we talked in the homework
about an operator Rn sub alpha,
which was exponential of
minus i alpha Sn over H bar.
Where n was a unit
vector, and Sn
is defined as n dot S.
So nxSx, nySy, nzSz.
So this operator
that you considered
was called the
rotation operator,
and it did perform
rotation of spin states.
In fact, what it did was rotate
any spin state by an angle,
alpha, around the nth direction.
So if you had the
n direction here,
and you had any spin state
in some arbitrary direction,
it would rotate it by an
angle alpha around this.
So you have this,
it would rotate it
to another point over here
with an angle alpha in between.
So in words, it rotates
by an angle alpha,
rotates spin states.
And when you think
of a spin state,
you must think of some n
vector, n prime vector.
So maybe n prime here
would be a good notation.
So you have a spin state
in the n prime direction.
Remember your spin states
were of the form n plus minus.
Well, the state that
points in the direction n
is n plus, so some
n prime direction.
This operator rotates those
states by an angle alpha.
Now, it probably is a little
vague in your mind, that idea,
because you checked
it several weeks ago.
And you only checked it by
taking some particular states
and rotating them.
So we will have to elaborate
on this, and we will.
So this will become
clear that this
rotates any spin state by
an angle alpha and rotates
spin states using an
axis, with respect
to the axis defined
by n over here.
So that's interpretation of
this state, of this operator.
That's what it does.
And now I want you to
look at this operator.
Well, it's similar.
In fact, this plays
the role of alpha,
and this plays the role of Sn.
So this is the spin
in the z direction,
and this operator
must rotate states
by this angle alpha,
which is gamma Bt.
If what we said is right, that's
what this operator must do.
Even though I think you've
done this calculation as part
of tests, problems,
or other problems,
practice problems,
not quite homework.,
I want to do this
calculation again.
So let's take an
arbitrary spin state, xyz.
Now, don't confuse the arbitrary
spin states with the n here.
The n is here the
axis around which
this Hamiltonian rotates states.
But there's no states here.
This is a rotation operator.
I'm sorry, I called
it a Hamiltonian.
It's not precise.
This is a unitary operator.
It rotates states.
And this is the direction,
the axis, of rotation.
Your spin state
is another object.
It's a spin that lives
in some direction.
So here, we're having
the magnetic field
in the z direction.
So the magnetic field is here.
And we'll put a spin state over
here, an n, a spin state that
has some value of phi
and some value of theta.
And that's the spin state
at time equals zero.
So psi 0 is the spin state this
that with your formula sheet,
this cosine theta over 2
plus plus sine theta over 2 e
to the i phi, I think
with a plus, yes.
I'll call it phi not, and
maybe theta 0, y 0, and minus.
So this is a state,
a spin state pointing
in this direction,
the direction n.
That was the general
formula for a spin state.
Now we are going to apply the
operator, the time evolution
operator.
But let's do a
preliminary calculation.
HS on plus is minus gamma B
Sz on plus minus gamma B H
bar over 2 plus, and Hs
minus is equal to minus
gamma BSz on minus equal plus
gamma B H bar over 2 minus.
So we want to add with this
operator on this state.
So here we have it,
the state that any time
is going to be E to the
minus iHst over H bar times
this state over here
acting on psi is 0.
So let's do it.
Well, on the first term
is cosine theta 0 over 2.
And you have this
exponent acting on plus.
But the exponent has Hs
that's acting on plus is this.
So you can just put that
thing on the exponent.
So you put e to the
minus i, and Hs on plus
is this, minus gamma
B H bar over 2.
Then you have the p and
the H bar and the plus.
And continue here.
So we just need to do the second
term, plus sine theta over 2,
e to the minus i.
And now the same thing,
but with a plus sign.
Plus gamma B H bar over 2, t
over H bar on the minus state.
So just in case I
got you confused
and the small type
is a problem here,
this operator active on initial
state just acts on plus,
then acts on minus.
On plus, the operator
is an eigen state.
So you can just put the
number in the exponential.
So you put the plus eigen
value, the minus eigen value.
So what do we get?
Psi t is equal, cosine
theta not over 2,
e to the i gamma B t over 2
plus sine theta not over 2, e
to the minus i gamma
B t over 2 minus.
Now, this state
this is not quite--
I hope I got my signs right.
Yes.
This state is not
quite in readable form.
To compare it with
a general end state,
you need null phase here.
So we must factor
this phase out.
e to the i gamma B t over 2.
And it's an irrelevant phase.
So then you have cosine theta
not over 2 plus sine theta not
over 2.
I'm sorry, I forgot to have
the e to the i phi not here.
I didn't copy it.
So here, what do we have?
e to the i phi not
minus gamma B t minus.
Look, when you
factor this one out,
you get minus the
same thing here.
So this becomes a minus 1.
And then you put the two faces
together, and you got that.
So now you look at
this state, and you
say, oh, I know what this is.
This is a spin
state that has theta
as a function of
time, just theta not.
But the angle, phi,
as a function of time
is phi not minus gamma B t.
So this spin will precess
and will go like this.
Phi not minus gamma B t is
the phi as a function of time.
So have the magnetic field.
You have a procession
of the spin over here.
So this is spin procession.
And indeed, this is exactly
what we're claiming here.
If this rotates states
by an angle alpha,
this operator, this Hamiltonian
that we've discussed here,
must rotate states by this angle
alpha, which is minus gamma Bt,
along the z-axis.
So you have the z-axis, and
you rotate by minus gamma Bt.
The sine is the reason the
phi decreases in time and goes
in this direction, as opposed
to going in the other direction.
So this is a basic confirmation
of what the spin is doing.
And I want to give
you the general result
so that you can really
use it more clearly.
So I think the lights
are gone, so we
can go to this blackboard.
First of all, classical picture.
What is it about
spin procession?
Is it a quantum phenomenon or a
classical phenomenon, or both?
Well, it's really both.
And this idea of
procession, you can get it
from the classical
picture as well.
So what do you have?
If you have a mu in a B
field, you get a torque.
And that you can easily
convince yourself.
I'm sure you've done
the computation in 802.
You have a little
square wire not
aligned with the magnetic field.
You calculate the force on one
side, the force on the other.
You see that there is a torque.
And the torque is given
by mu cross B. That's enm.
On the other hand, the rate
of change of angular momentum
is the torque.
So this is mu cross B.
But mu is gamma S, so this
is gamma S cross B. And this
is minus gamma B cross S.
OK.
This equation, which I
rewrite it here, ds/dt equals
minus gamma B cross S,
is a particular case
of a very famous equation
in classical mechanics,
and this equation for
a rotating vector.
If you have a vector,
dx/dt is omega cross x.
This is the equation
satisfied by a vector
x that is rotating
with angular frequency
omega around the axis
defined by the vector omega.
A famous equation.
OK, so you have here
omega vector is omega n.
So here is the direction
of n, the unit vector.
Here's omega.
And you have a
vector x over here.
Then this vector, the
solution of this equation,
is a vector that is rotating
around omega with the angular
velocity magnitude of omega.
In the notes, I just
give a little hint
of how you derive that.
But truly speaking,
you guys should
be able to just
scribble a few notes
if you don't know the situation
by heart, and convince yourself
this is true.
So this equation is
of that form in which
the omega x is played by
S. Omega is minus gamma B.
So this defines what is called
the Larmor frequency, which
is minus gamma B, is
the Larmor frequency.
Now, this Larmor
frequency is precisely
that one because
was minus gamma B.
And here you have
minus gamma B times t.
Omega times t is the angle.
So in fact, this is rotating
with a Larmor frequency.
And there you go.
In the same blackboard, you
have a classical mechanics
derivation of the
Larmor frequency
and a quantum
mechanical derivation
of the Larmor frequency.
Again, at the end of the
day, this is no coincidence.
We've made dynamical
classical variables
into quantum operators, and we
haven't changed the physics.
Mu dot B is a classical energy.
Well, it became Hamiltonian,
and it's doing the right thing.
So we can now use
the Larmor frequency
to rewrite the
Hamiltonian, of course.
It's here.
So a little bit of
emphasis is worth it.
Hs is minus mu dot B, and
it's minus gamma B dot S,
and it's finally equal
to omega L dot S.
So if somebody gives
you a Hamiltonian
that at the end of the
day, you can write it
as some vector dot S, you
already know that for spins,
that is the Larmor
frequency of rotation.
It's a very simple thing.
Hs, something times
S, well that's
precisely the rotation
frequency for the spin states.
They will all rotate that way.
So we can say that the spin
states in this Hamiltonian
rotate with omega L frequency.
So that's good.
That's a general discussion of
precession in a magnetic field.
But I want to go one more
step in generalization.
It's a simple step,
but let's just take it.
So that you see
even more generally
why any system can be
thought of as a spin system.
And this is quite practical.
In fact, it's
probably the best way
to imagine physically, the
effects of any Hamiltonian.
So let's consider
time-independent Hamiltonians
the most general Hamiltonian
for a two-state system.
How can it be?
Well, a two-state
system, remember
two-state system is a word.
It really means a system
with two basis states.
Once you have two basis
states, a plus and the minus
have infinitely many
states, of course.
But two-state system
is two basis states.
And therefore, in
the Hamiltonian,
in this two basis states,
is a 2 by 2 matrix.
And it's a 2 by 2
Hermitian matrix.
So there's not too
much it can be.
In fact, you can have
a constant that I
will call maybe not the base
notation, g not and g not.
And that's Hermitian.
It's real constant.
You can put a g3 and a minus g3.
That's still Hermitian.
And that's reasonable.
There's no reason why this
number should be equal to this.
So there are two numbers here
that are arbitrary, real.
And therefore, you can put
them wherever you want.
And I decided to call one g not
plus g3 and one g not minus g3.
Here, I can put again an
arbitrary complex number,
as long as I put here
the complex conjugate.
So I will call this g1 minus
ig2, and this g1 plus ig2.
And that's the most
general 2 by 2 Hamiltonian.
Tonya If those would be
time-dependent functions,
this is the most general
Hamiltonian ever for a 2
by 2 system.
It doesn't get more complicated.
That's a great
advantage of this.
But I've written it
in a way that you
can recognize something.
You can recognize
that this is g not
times the identity plus g1 times
sigma 1 plus g2 times sigma
2 plus g3 times sigma 3.
And this is because the
Pauli matrices are, together
with the unit matrix, a
basis for all Hermitian 2
by 2 matrices.
So the Pauli matrices
are Hermitian.
The unit matrix is Hermitian.
The most general 2
by 2 Hermitian matrix
is a number times the one
matrix, then number times
the first part, then number,
second, number, third.
OK.
So at this moment, we've got
the most general Hamiltonian.
And I will write it as g
not times 1 plus g vector
dot sigma, where g
vector is g1, g2, g3.
If we write the g
vector as length
of g, which is
just the letter g,
shouldn't be confused because
we have g not, g1, g2, g3,
but we haven't had a
g without an index.
So g without an index is
going to be the magnitude of g
vector, and n is going to
be a particular vector.
So look, you're talking about
the most general Hamiltonian,
and you're saying it's
most easily understood
as g not multiplying
the identity, and that g
vector multiplying
the sigma vector.
So on the other hand, g is this.
So this is also g not 1
plus g times n dot sigma.
But let's continue here.
We know how to
solve this problem.
And you can say,
well, all right.
I have to diagonalize this
matrix, find the eigen vectors,
find the eigenvalues,
and all that.
But you've done all that work.
It's already been done.
What were the eigen states?
Well, n dot sigma,
the eigen states
were the end states, the
spin states, n plus minus.
And they were plus minus
n comma plus minus.
Remember that S
is H over 2 sigma.
So this corresponds to n dot
S on n plus minus equal plus
minus H bar over 2
n plus minus, which
might be the form in which
you remember it better.
But the sigma
matrices, n dot sigma
is diagonalized
precisely by this thing.
So in fact, you never have
to diagonalize this matrix.
It's already been done for you.
And these are the eigen
states of this Hamiltonian.
And what is the value of
the energy on n plus minus?
Well, energy on n plus minus
is g not times 1 plus g n
dot sigma on the n plus minus.
And g not times 1
here on this state
is g not plus g n dot sigma,
the thing is plus minus.
So plus minus g, n plus minus.
So in fact, you
have the energies,
and you have the eigen vectors.
So the eigen states are n plus
with energy equal g not plus g
and n minus with energy
equal g not minus g.
So what we did by inventing
the Pauli matrices
and inventing spin
states and all
that was solve for
you the most general 2
by 2 Hamiltonian,
Hermitian Hamiltonian.
If you have a 2 by
2 Hermitian matrix,
you don't have to
diagonalize it by hand.
You know the answers
are this state.
And how do you
build those states?
Well, you know what n is
because you know the g's.
If you know the three g's,
you know what the vector g is.
You know what the vector n is.
You know what this g is as well.
And therefore, with
a vector n, you
construct this state, as
you know already very well.
And given that you
know g and g not,
well the energies are
this, at the splitting
is 2g between those states.
This is the ground state.
This is the excited state.
Splitting two g's, so you
look at the Hamiltonian,
and you say, what's the
splitting between the two eigen
states of this.
You just take this numbers,
compute g, and multiply by 2.
Now, last thing
that you would want
to do with this Hamiltonian
is time evolution.
So what do we say
about time evolution?
Well, we have here
H is equal to this.
And we also had omega L dot
S. So omega L dot S in here
should be identified with this.
So sigma and S, as you remember,
S is equal H bar over 2 sigma.
So this term can be
written as g vector sigma.
In fact, this is
better from here.
g vector sigma, and
sigma is H bar over 2S.
I got a 2 over H bar.
2 over H bar S.
So from here, g dot sigma is
2g over H bar S. And remember,
a Hamiltonian for a
spin system, whatever's
multiplying the vector
that is multiplying S
is omega L. So in
this system-- I
will write it like that--
omega L is 2g over H bar.
And this is a great
physical help.
Because now that
you have this, I
should remark this
part of the Hamiltonian
is the one that does procession.
A part proportional to the
identity cannot do procession,
is just a constant term that
produces a constant phase,
just produces a pure phase.
That's a change,
an overall phase
that doesn't change the state.
You would have an extra factor
of e to the minus i times
that constant, g
not t over H bar,
multiplying all the states.
Doesn't change the action
on plus or minus state.
It's an overall phase.
This term in the Hamiltonian
is almost never very important.
It doesn't do anything
to the physical states,
just gives them pure phases.
And this term is the
thing that matters.
So now with this
Hamiltonian, because g
dot sigma is the form
of the Hamiltonian,
and we've identified this
physical phenomenon of Larmor
frequency, if you know your
vector g for any Hamiltonian,
this might be the [INAUDIBLE]
for ammonia molecule,
then you know how the
states evolve in time.
Because you represent the state.
You have one state
and a second state.
You think of the one
state as the plus
of a spin, the minus of a spin.
And then you know that this
is processing with this Larmor
frequency.
So it may sound a little
abstract at this moment,
but this gives you the way
to evolve any arbitrary state
intuitively.
You know the vector
V where it points.
You know where your state points
in the configuration space.
And you have a physical picture
of what it does in time.
It's always precessing.
Therefore, the dynamics of
a two-state system in time
is always procession, and
that's what we have to learn.
So next time will be ammonia
molecule, and then NMR.